previously on TV since an average which
is born with a few natural gifts but in
each generation in every generation
there is a chosen one she alone will
stand against the vampires
[Music]
I think something this nice should be
saved for a special occasion oh no no
that's the beauty part it goes except
for gold you don't want to wear gold on
gold I've seen I'm gonna get you sucker
enough times to know how you cheat cause
of death looks like goji / go have any
idea what this will do for your sex life
probably slow it down at first but once
I get used to the extra weight I'll be
back on track in case she needed to be
reminded the Chandler is left-handed and
the fact that he jerks off a lot and if
I want to call for reference on your
last job
oh that's there on the bottom see the
manager Chandler Bing - this resume
fraud but like Chandler wouldn't Ross or
Rachel be more reliable at fudging
Monica's work history and is there no
one other than her boss at a previous
job that would bout four she's an
exemplary employee well I'm tearing the
lettuce is it dirty
oh no no don't worry I'm gonna wash it
don't I like it dirty
this pervy restaurant manager is
literally asking Monica to toss his
salad and the laugh track thinks that's
hilarious
I don't get it I mean two months ago
Rachel they were like this close right
now what I'm taking messages from guys
she she meets at the movies it's time we
had a talk about the crack cocaine that
is will they won't they the network
execs are addicted to it and they're
gonna be mainline on that for a full ten
seasons man for life nope turns out male
lobsters in particular or rather
promiscuous some lobsters do have a
monogamous bond but it usually only
lasts for two weeks in fact when it
comes to the love life of a lobster
they're 100 percent shellfish we talked
about that but your brother has so many
science trophies and plaques and merit
badges well we didn't want to disturb
them the science trophies and the
plaques I understand but merit badges
merit badges we don't need no stinking
merit badges well I can't say any of us
were surprised your parents have been
unhappy ever since we've known them I
know mr. Geller is a little garrulous
and unseemly at times but this is
full-on social idea see he knows better
than the shake like this - Rachel even
Oaks like Frank and Estelle Costanza had
a tiny amount of decor dude o'clock
totally hot babe checking us which
Phoebe said at full volume so the hot
babe could hear Pheebs does not know how
to wingman also thieves needs to learn
how to read a clock because this woman
checking out Chandler
be at his five o'clock also also a lot
of Chandler's arc on the show is that
he's unlucky with women even sometimes
repulsive but this amazingly attractive
random woman is hogging him and he
barely bats an eye that's really good
I think I'm ready for my penis oddly
enough this is exactly how my college
girlfriend signed off from all of our
phone calls I know what you're thinking
Dave Thomas founder of Wendy's Chandler
one of the most likable and funny sitcom
characters of all time if we given him
his due yet I think it's time to reverse
ding the Bing we're just doing some
impressions over here do your Marcell
myself that's actually good
man this group was totally written
during the off season and they just had
to manufacture a reason to shoehorn it
in are you Rachel
well I'm God in your head you said you
were pretty but Wow god damn it friends
is a great Network sitcom but it also
firmly establishes the ceiling for sits
and comps how does this actually break
up this budding romance in any plausible
way well yeah um you're my Lobster
little-known fact all your gross lengths
on most films are inspired by episodes
of friends I believe the movie the
killing of the sacred deer was based on
an episode called the one with all the
pointless staring and nonsensical half
metaphors that after watching felt like
someone has removed your Cohn ads and
played tetherball with them but I could
be mistaken lobsters in the tank when
when they're old they get with they walk
around this character is supposedly
excellent at teaching facts about
prehistoric life to people just FYI we
are never gonna happen okay except that
very cool even this episode can't accept
that what do you say yeah we play some
ball you and me how would he say let
Minnesota Timberwolves
bring on the hey we'll handle the
repetitive exclamations Along Came Polly
I've got something that's gonna make you
happy I'm assuming this is the line that
lands Rachel a lot of first dates in
future episodes that's what they'll call
us feels like we spent a good bit of
this episode on a plotline that affects
the overall series about as much as the
creepy salad guy at the beginning Oh
Monica what's on this videotape why it
appears to be the entire basis for this
episode of the show yeah it's only
introduced with a few minutes left
weird right sheesh with this and the
Rachel knows jokes I'm pretty sure we
were more shallow in the 90s than the
entire chorus of that one Lady Gaga song
for a star is born also I get the 1996
makeup effects in
but considering the Nutty Professor came
out the same year I'm pretty comfortable
calling this fat suit episode steals our
outtake
you know Roy saw Star Wars 317 times
poor bastard was born in the wrong era
these days he'd get a plaque delivered
by Bob Iger himself for accomplishing
this feat as if this braun video wasn't
already staged and blocked perfectly for
a fact it also has a repeat of Ross
falling up the stairs in slow motion
mm-hmm
how lucky that these stairway flowers
just happen to be here what a beautiful
bouquet of convenient iums
whoa they're sitting I get that it's a
Ross and Rachel thing and that's a
pretty great kissing moment but when you
really think about it it's that moment
unearned she's been pretty adamant all
episode that she wants nothing to do
with it but somehow that little trip
down memory lane changes things that
drastically and that quickly if anything
it's a wash so I'm gonna need you to
give those sins back Sydney remember
stab turn trick I don't have the knife
yes you do check your clutch
thanks man now I can get my pony figure
some immigrants gonna have a pony
no it's not flashy not for a good fella
like I'm a clown may amuse you I make
you laugh I'm here to amuse you
I mean I'm 56 years old and I got to
start using condoms dad and it's crazy
stuff for the time you get it out of the
package you lose your yeah dad talk
about me oh you didn't maybe I didn't
I'm gonna go beat up the food and to me
them line please talk to me please
you're part of my life you know
everything I could not go on without you
Lisa
Pheebs you want to help me out with the
whole lobster thing do the claws again
Oh
watch yourself it's Nicole oh I'm tired
of being clobbered we were on a break oh
you're right I should play in the hay
how about I just go eat some hay I can
make things out of clay and lay by the
bay I just may what do you say